Speaker 1: Let's go to a win from Indiana.
Win?
Go.
Speaker 3: Hi, can you hear me all right?
Speaker 1: Yeah, I can hear you fine.
Speaker 3: Awesome.
So I have a question on economics again.
So I'm currently taking macroeconomics and
I've learned the effects of spending and saving.
You mentioned a lot about the marginal propensity
to consume.
Yes.
And the multiplier effect.
The idea that if you stimulate the poor, that
leads to an increase in GDP and economic growth
and whatnot.
But my question is.
So my question is, if you so the theory is
that if you stimulate the or like demand rate
it, it assumes that prices are stickier, which
is our prices don't change in the long in
the short term, I believe.
So do you think in the real world, prices
are really sticky?
Speaker 1: It depends on the industry and
it depends on the time horizon.
So I mean, I'll give you an example.
So like in the short term, if you take something
like gas prices, gas prices respond to demand
and they also, as we're seeing right now,
gas prices respond to supply.
But if you think about, for example, the type
of demand changes that it takes to move gas
prices.
We had a pandemic where global air travel
reduced dramatically.
People driving reduced dramatically and we
saw gas prices go down.
But for the most part, if we talk about some
stimulus, some demand side stimulus for the
lower middle class in the United States, the
amount by which their demand for gas will
increase is not really going to have an impact
on gas prices.
It's too modest.
So that's an example of where the additional
money to be able to, you know, maybe take
a road trip or whatever it will change the
sort of life of the person getting the money
and now having more money for gas without
really changing the price of gas in a significant
way.
It's sort of like asymmetrical, if that makes
sense.
So so I think the question is always of what
good or service and over what time period
is what we have to ask.
Speaker 3: I see so when we implement like
specific policies.
We have to look which industry, right, and
then because some some demand side stimulus
may be a negative at a disadvantage towards
some industry too.
And with that, would that would you consider
that like good policy?
Does the fact that it's affecting a different
industry, let's say the service industry or
the industry that is not really like a necessity,
so well,
Speaker 1: it's it's getting a little bit
muddled what you're saying.
But I think what I think the question you're
sort of asking is if we think about demand
side stimulus as just being good because it
gives people more money to spend on stuff,
don't we also need to consider that increased
demand as a result of those people having
more money can increase prices, and that might
not be so good.
Speaker 3: Yeah, yeah.
Yeah, that's much.
Face it.
Speaker 1: You really have to look at it more
specifically.
And you also have to remember that in traditional
economic thinking, a little bit of inflation
is considered good.
You don't want too much inflation and you
don't want deflation, and I've talked through
the internal logic of that.
So just because some demand side stimulus
will cause a little bit of inflation also
doesn't mean it's bad.
I apologize because there's really not one
answer to this.
Speaker 3: Right, right, right.
I agree.
Speaker 1: But it sounds like you're generally
understanding the concept, which is the most
important thing.
Speaker 3: Yeah, because I'm in like this.
I don't know, like the middle phase kind of
like, I don't know what to unders like, read
or understand.
And I'm just wondering they want to find the
truth to this.
But there's again, there's a lot of economic
data backing up the demand side stimulus.
I mean, demand side policy.
Speaker 1: Yeah.
I mean, listen, you're asked, you seem to
be bringing the right amount of skepticism
to the things that you're learning, which
is fantastic.
Speaker 3: Yeah, yeah.
Awesome.
And one one really quick last question.
Do you so?
What are your thoughts on saving and economic
growth, because there's also some data on
that, like countries that say war leads to.
They tend to have a higher economic growth.
What were your thoughts on that?
Speaker 1: Well, so there's a difference between
the micro and the macro level.
I mean, we've talked before about how given
the option of.
Giving a tax cut to a very rich person or
a poor person, the rich person is more likely
to just sock the money in a bank account because
they don't really need that money to live,
whereas the poor person is more likely to
spend it and the spending has a higher multiplier
than the saving in a bank account.
So that's like the individual level.
At the same time, saving at the macroeconomic
level, meaning how much is society saving
in total is a sign of economic health because
it means you don't have a society with as
many people on the brink of not being able
to afford basic expenses.
So when we think about who do we want to target
for tax refunds or tax credits, we would have
one answer to that.
And we might say, well, just putting the money
in a bank account is not so good as in terms
of a multiplier at the macroeconomic level,
a higher savings rate within reason is a sign
of economic health.
So the answer is different depending on whether
you're talking about macro or micro.
Speaker 3: OK, OK, because but if we're targeting,
if you want for the benefit of society, you
know, obviously GDP is not everything, right?
No, I'd like for the benefit of society then.
Probably tax cuts for the for the wealthy
isn't really the best option currently.
Speaker 1: That's what the data show.
Speaker 3: Yeah, OK.
OK.
Got it.
All right.
Thank you so much, David.
Speaker 1: Thanks.
When we'll win with some of the meatiest economics
questions we've had in a while.
I absolutely love it.
All right, everybody.
We're going to go to a break.
We will take calls again soon.